[Music]
hey dad
i know you can hear us you see your eyes
opening
it's just so special to see you there's
so many people
have just been asking about you calling
writing texting
he can hear he can hear him see his eyes
he can hear us
private battles in sealed off rooms the
business of saving lives
is intense and brutal and if you spend
enough time here you realize in this
crisis
the whole system is on life support
and the question becomes whether the
staff and the nhs itself
will ever recover it's been
a living nightmare to work we've lost
people in their 30s
in their 40s it's heartbreaking
this is held we cannot continue like
this i am one
of the person who ignores all the
message
but no is it true can kill you you're
getting out dima
you're getting out i've never been into
an institution
that's been willing to just lift up a
lid and say look we're in a crisis
[Music]
as winter arrives these health workers
are heading into the greatest challenge
they've ever faced it seemed like this
tsunami of people came in christmas
nights it was the first time ever that
i've come into work feeling
like i can't breathe
by mid-january the number of people in
hospital with covid19 in the united
kingdom
has reached 38 000. we have no clue
nobody prepared us to you know to deal
with a situation like this this is new
for us all
we've been allowed access to the royal
free and barnet hospitals in north
london
for months filming to follow the stories
of patients and
staff during the peak of the worst
crisis
in the history of the nhs on our arrival
at the royal free
there are 307 coveted positive patients
taking up two-thirds of the 12-storey
building
many of them are in intensive care we've
got 86
87 patients one coming down to 87. and
how many of those are on
ventilators i think 84. so
but the hospital only has a limited
number of specialist
icu nurses trained in using those
ventilators
first thing that comes to my mind is how
many patients i'm having today
and how many helpers are going to be
around
we never really know what we're walking
into so it could be a really busy shift
every patient is
so sick and requires so much nurse
attention which makes it even more
challenging
every single nurse here still wants to
give exactly the same level of care
but there's another person coming
through and another person coming
through
i remember coming in christmas night i'd
been with my family in the daytime i
came in christmas night
and we'd gone from looking after two
patients to
four to six patients per person uh per
person
even though i'd gone through the first
surge it was probably the scariest
experience of my whole nursing career
i only slept two hours last night but i
need
i'm tired and i needed to sleep but when
you're running on adrenaline
there is no choice you know it's not oh
i can't do this today there
is no choice if you have so many
patients you have so many patients you
just have to get on with it
nicholas has been assigned a room that
would normally house recovering surgery
patients but has now been transformed
into a hot cramped coveid intensive care
ward
[Music]
a patient with an endotracheal tube we
have to keep them very very heavily
sedated
otherwise they wouldn't tolerate the
tube and there is more risk of
infections
let's bring it down a little bit
but it's definitely better than
comparing to yesterday
they require high doses of oxygen and
they require high support from the
ventilators
that gentlemen seems to be improving a
little bit so we have managed to
remove the endotracheal tube and doing a
surgical tracheostomy
which means he's breathing from the neck
below the mouth exactly
how's working life at the moment
compared to what you're used to well
i'm i feel like i want to cry in many
moments i mean
i can do my job properly but i would
like to ask people to
to bear in mind that this is this is
held we cannot continue like this
the atmosphere is that of an army field
hospital
where all hands are on deck
i've been in nursing for 35 years and
i've never seen anything like this
my biggest worry is whether we've got
enough staff to get through the next 24
hours
that's 48 hours because i know what the
impact is going to be if we don't have
enough staff for
the staff and patients and i think
that's the thing that that keeps me
awake at night
this week we've had the army in yes i
saw the army had arrived
that's right so that's a help oh it's a
huge help actually
everyone's mucking in if not army medics
it's medical students
even surgeons acting as nurses lucy
barker a consultant from moorfields eye
hospital
now clearing airways next to her evelyn
and patricia putting mittens on a 41
year old covid patient to stop her
pulling at the tubes
i'm an occupational therapist but we
usually work for the children's team
and we're just redeployed at the moment
so helping out okay so you've come down
from pediatrics
we're in the community so we've come in
from the community
and we work in the schools around camden
so you normally work with special needs
children
yep here you are dealing with the sharp
end of a massive pandemic
yes yeah we're very flexible we're very
depressed
that is really flexible add to that
specialists pulled in from every corner
of the hospital
stretching its resources to the limit
everyone has a role to play because
covert is a multi-system disease
we see kidney issues we see liver issues
we see clots and we can we see heart
attacks
and apart from the devastating effect it
can have on the land
and that's what's so frightening for the
patients there's no way of knowing
what this disease will do 73 year old
lorry driver tony
is precariously ill what do you want to
know
how are you feeling i absolutely
terrible
if people would have taken a lot more
care
when this come out and then
ignored it we wouldn't mean such a mess
we're in we wouldn't have had so many
deaths
too many people of christopher
and the nhs are fantastic
for what they're doing what they've got
to put up with
they're brilliant we just all know
that we will live and come out of it
i'll tell you anyone of course we do
tony speaks for everyone who ends up in
a place like this
okay terry when you're ready you're
gonna give me a nice big cough
nice big cough for me good lady
fantastic survival is brutal
in intensive care tubes need to be
inserted
and taken out kept from infection
lines are plugged into the artery in the
neck to administer drugs and anaesthetic
what kind of medicines are you using
you're better asking them
we don't normally work up here we're
kind of coming up to put the lines in
so the itu staff can use them but it'll
so this isn't normally your we don't
normally work up here
no what do you normally do we work in
radiology
consultant mike spiro normally splits
his time between intensive care and the
hospital's liver transplant department
which has had to shut down to free up
space and manpower
for the covert influx he's now helping
to manage an icu department
at three times its normal capacity i
just think it's staggering this has
become a normal way to practice medicine
it just makes everything so much more
difficult
and and for awake patients very very
scary i mean intensive care at the best
of times is a scary place to be
yeah a lot of people have problems with
with delirium and intensive care where
they hallucinate
and obviously when we're dressed up in
in full bb it can be utterly terrifying
so we can now go in
how are you feeling um
i feel uh what have you always
been yeah not quite there yet yeah yeah
yes but you remember where you were
we're at a situation within the whole of
london at the moment
whereby we are having to consider
transferring patients out
long range to outside of london how far
might they have to move
at the moment we're looking at the
midlands
they are near full capacity too on the
cpap wards
this is a step down from intensive care
so he's not short of breath for anything
here patients aren't using internal
tubes for ventilation
and are conscious but appearances can be
deceptive
it's been a very tough couple of weeks
we've had loads of patients come in
deteriorated
and we've sent many patients to
intensive care and a lot of patients are
just very scared and i would be as well
i like to just sit with my patients and
just kind of hold their hand and just
say you know
we'll hope that everything goes well but
we can't we don't we have to be
realistic with ourselves and with
patients as well so
you can't promise them that it's going
to promise anything no no
[Music]
wrestling very bad every one
night why i went to ring your wife
the lord weren't coming what's your
wife's name
linda oh mr when's the last time you saw
linda
i was three weeks ago
got really amazing
that is one of the hardest things i'm
sure not being able to see
your wife
i hope through one though i don't feel
it's all right now
i don't want anything else in life
tony didn't make it a day after this
interview
he died linda was with him via
videophone
this virus isolates before it kills
[Music]
behind the glass and the warning tape
the care is round the clock and
relentless but nothing
can replace a son a daughter a wife
at the end of the bed and like tony
everyone in here just quietly hopes
they can get out
[Music]
the last few weeks have been basically
a whirlwind it's been a living nightmare
to work it's another world entirely
we do as pauses as general pauses
part of our job is mortary but on this
scale
no we none of us have known the like of
it
a little sort of bridge of normality
that's what pauses are we're not giving
you drugs we're taking your procedure
talking about the weather
football whatever you know and and you
do
strike up a rapport with patients
you can go and collect a patient fate
may have dictated you've taken them
before he said hello jerry
hello jackie hello matt and
will that the upside is when they go
home
but during this
it's hard to put into words but they may
not be with us anymore so
that's when it all really is let out
when i can you know have a little cry
and whatever yeah but here it's just
what you it's your job off you go you've
got to
keep going
during the month of january in the royal
free and barnet hospitals
347 patients die of covid19
there is no pacemaker
there is nothing on the face or ears
it's an unpredictable disease youth and
previous good health
don't guarantee survival we care for
patients they're patients they're not
bodies
they're not cadavers they're not you
know they're still patients
we treat them as they are the mortuary
has doubled its capacity on last year
but it's as full
as the wards upstairs four patients
behind nearly every door and jerry
has more on the way it's a bit you know
heartbreaking coming every day to do
this and still have people
telling to your face that this is not
real or that this is the flu
when you open these fridge doors
sometimes you must see some quite
young faces as well yeah yes yes
definitely
it's all ages really like uh
we have patients that they're my age or
even younger than me
the hardest i think it's when you see
someone that maybe reminds you of
somebody else that you know
or a familiar name or or a familiar age
you know like you know you think
automatically about your family
or your friends a red asterisk
marks a patient with covid and this is
by nearly every name
laura too has noticed a change in the
people coming here particularly the
first time we're definitely all the
patients but it
seems more varied this time it seems to
be a much wider
age group of patient that we're getting
into our care
you've got a career you've got a
retirement you've got the rest of your
life
ahead of you and then suddenly you don't
[Music]
[Laughter]
four floors up there's yet another
makeshift intensive care ward
critical care normally requires one
nurse to each patient
but the covert influx means the ratio on
this ward is four patients
to every nurse you're in a bay on your
own trying to manage
multiple patients and it just makes it
really difficult and we're not even in
an ipv ward this is out
no so this is actually an outpatient
ward that we've had to turn into an it
would and that also comes with its
challenges so
it's really difficult as you can see in
these bedspaces to try and fit all the
itu equipment in we're trying to cram it
into small spaces
we're just running out of things like
plugs for example we don't physically
have enough plug sockets in some areas
probably with a lot of our patients a
lot of them will be long term so they'll
be with us for
uh
i juggle about a million balls at one
time yeah if you've got four patients in
here you must have eyes on the back of
your head yeah
because one thing can go you're trying
to watch everyone's blood pressure
everyone's observations
everyone's ventilation at the same time
but these are the moments that make it
all worthwhile
[Music]
just bear with us we're trying to get
you as comfy as you can be yeah
squeeze my hand again squeeze this one
again
dima hooper who's 53 is regaining
consciousness
for the first time since arriving at
hospital but now you're a bit more awake
can you try to lift my hands up
[Music]
well i'll let you go now
[Music]
uh
we gently reduce the amount of sedation
that patients are on to trying to
achieve a sort of balance where
they will tolerate the tube and tolerate
the ventilator and then bit by bit we
hope over the next few days
taking that maybe not even that long we
can reduce the amount of support she
needs and she can take over
and the ventilator can just go into the
background did you give me a thumbs up
so you can hear me really well oh
fantastic
it's great to see you with energy
well done it's a promising sign
but with this disease nothing can be
taken for granted
there's an inherent unpredictable nature
of of covered and how it
that the impact has on different people
people can seem to be improving and then
we'll take
steps back sometimes because of the
virus itself and sometimes because of
super added infections and other
problems i think unlikely covered
these medics are still learning about
covid daily meetings at barnet to
discuss patients
mean they can draw on each other's
experience
my sense is we should bring her down to
the cpap unit
and the issue at the moment is we do not
have a bid
available on the cpap unit as far as i
know so we might need to have a chat to
itu
to see if we can do a three-way juggle
often the hardest questions on what
treatment and what chance
of survival i don't think there's any
other management that will be helpful at
this point in time and i think it's
going to probably
be sensible to update his family that he
may have a guarded prognosis
can i just ask what a guarded prognosis
um so
it may be that unfortunately he doesn't
have a very good outcome from the
coronavirus pneumonia
so he's got a relatively high chance of
dying from korean virus
in previous times breaking bad news was
usually once
we degenerated a rapport with family and
also family had been able to
to see what we'd been doing now it comes
as a very
cold process essentially we're informing
family that they should come in because
their
loved one's going to die and and that's
a huge step of trust i think for
um somebody they've never met before
phones them and talks to them
and tells them the most dreadful news um
are there some patients who
you know that it's going to be futile to
ventilate them the much harder question
is when it's likely to be futile
but you can't guarantee that
and the chances of success are small
and the likelihood of suffering great
but it might work those are the hardest
patients to deal with
not because sending them to intensive
care is hard
the hard but is known whether you've
done the right thing for the patient
if you deteriorate will you like us to
put you to sleep and put a tube in your
mouth
and put you on breathing support
[Music]
you are not going to deteriorate that's
good good thinking
but there is a possibility so you have
to tell us
what you want us to do
these are the difficult decisions made
between patients and doctors
getting wired up and plugged in is
grueling okay
and now the screening is really caught
speeding
twist and push through and change keep
pushing and stressing
it's quite brutal
it can be several weeks before medics
know whether the trauma of intensive
care
has paid off nikolai was one of the
sickest patients we had admitted in
december he was incredibly unwell he was
um on all the treatments we had he
needed the full ventilator help for for
many many weeks
um there were many nights when most of
us thought that he wouldn't be there the
following day
but after more than a month on a
ventilator this is the first time
62 year old nikolai yasachi responds to
his daughters and
tell you grandchildren relieved we are
how happy we are
how thankful to god and all the care he
had from you
there in the royal free hospital how
long has he been in intensive care
uh he's been more than 40 days from the
6th of december
till now that must be very traumatic
time for your family
yes but we never lost pope he's a
miracle we just thank to god
my dad age 59 michael
is barely conscious when his family
called by video
you know you can hear us you see your
eyes opening
he can hear he can hear his eyes he can
hear
the familiar voices do seem to stir a
reaction
[Music]
but amid the comforting sounds of hope
trying to soothe him back to life
in the opposite bay the patient has
succumbed to the virus
the porters have arrived
jerry's here to take this patient in his
early 60s
down to the mortuary you've got a family
over here
yeah talking to a loved one yeah and
then you're at the same time you've got
someone being ruled out who's just died
who presumably you you've been caring
for
yeah how's that feel it's really
upsetting and i think on a
on sort of a daily level you're sort of
having to
talk to families and reassure them but
at the same time you might have patients
that are really sadly passing away
in literally the bay officer and it's
just trying to i think shield that from
patients and families and try and make
things look as normal
as possible but it's really difficult
but it's not normal
no this is not normal this is not normal
at all
[Music]
all the ambulances have just arrived at
once so why is this the witching hour i
don't know
for the last few weeks so from about
four o'clock onwards it's just
all of a sudden become very busy
[Music]
late january covid case numbers have
dipped
but there are still 3 000 new hospital
admissions
every day across the uk and at barnet a
e seven ambulances have arrived at once
as they come in the door we have to work
out what their risk of hoping is to
protect our staff and our patients
there's quite a lot of people that have
got delirious for instance
or um they have another problem that
they fall over
and they've broken their hip but
actually they've fallen over because
they're so weak from coughing from cobia
so it's not always straight away
apparent
that coverts lurking
[Music]
he's quite sad his wife died on friday
while he was being treated in here oh my
god
63 year old post office cleaner felix
ramott is not only grieving for his wife
he's now dangerously unwell
it will help you to himself okay
the virus has ripped through his family
felix's 40 year old son-in-law is also
in the hospital
on a ventilator yeah is it coming off
yeah it is coming up
if we had a bed then we would just take
him immanently but at the moment we
trying to figure out which would be the
best place for him to go
it's the start of a frightening often
solitary and testing journey
many patients have been here weeks even
months
surviving this disease is one thing
recovering from it is a whole other
process
[Music]
it's great to see you doing so well dima
was touch and go but a week on from when
we filmed her waking up
she's stronger it must be nice to be
just sat up and
out of the bed yeah are you feeling a
lot better
yeah we look forward to when we can talk
to you properly
[Music]
two days and then you'll be able to talk
okay i won't push it but you've been
walking today
yesterday you started walking amazing
amazing you are incredible
you look strong yeah you look strong
can you assess at this stage the impact
that virus has had on her long term
um her ct scan shows that she's she's
had bad
covered pneumonitis even with the
tracheostomy and we've seen that she's
got
strength we've seen she's able to stand
um i would expect her to do well
but how how that will affect her lungs
10 15 years down the line
only time will tell even when the icu
patients are unconscious
medics are already working on their
physical rehabilitation
[Music]
physiotherapist claire is doing what's
called ranging
making sure the patient's joints don't
stiffen up so movement
will come back more easily
lovely can't let these knees hips get
this
hand i noticed you were talking to the
patient do you know whether they can
hear you
sometimes you hear from our previous
survivors like they
they say they remember like hearing
accents rather than actual words but i
just think
he's a person i'm gonna tell him what
i'm doing you're working in an
environment
where it's pretty much unprecedented
numbers of people dying yeah and i just
wonder how that feels for you
um it's
i think this sounds silly but the worst
thing is when we do our ward books in
the morning
and it's when the amount of rips
outnumbers the ones that have made it
down to the wards
and i think that's when it really kicks
in and
they're a lot younger in the first wave
sorry i remember thinking that could be
mum
that could be my aunt and now i'm
thinking that could be me that could be
my brother
my boyfriend
you're seeing those people every day
that you're working on and
and really noticing the difference in
their age yeah they're a lot younger
this time
we lost people in their 30s in their 40s
it's heartbreaking well thank you very
much for talking to us
take care
[Music]
and this is why claire's work is so
important
a week on from when we last saw him
nikolai is about to get on his feet
[Music]
okay are you ready
i was really taken back by how many
people were so debilitated like not just
physically but
we deal a lot with the cognitive side of
things and we'd have
patients who were like hugely you know
independent like
running their own businesses lawyers who
actually
were really confused and and couldn't
manage to do basic tasks
well done but it does look as if
the the process of rehabilitation
is a long arduous one yeah
definitely it's like a marathon yeah
that you have to train for that's what
we explain it to the patients as
samarathan austrians
[Music]
is that all right michael is also
recovering
you remember us how are you feeling
today
not too bad when we came back last time
you were on the
video to your family would you say
you're kind of aware of their voices
when yeah yeah even when you were
sort of semi-conscious do you think you
could hear them
yeah is that quite comforting
yeah in a week or so we'll have a
proper conversation with you that'd be
nice wouldn't it
for dima it's only a matter of days
before she gets her
voice back i can speak you can speak
we can hear you it's amazing yeah i'm
moving up to the
board dima tells me she hadn't realised
she had covered
and had got antibiotics from her gp
because she'd been vomiting
but then she began to feel famed my
roommates
so you were feeling sick had you so
you'd passed out i didn't even know i
just
remember getting really happy and that
was it
yeah do you remember anything else i
woke up
i don't think i was here and then
saw you guys you saw her
the first thing you saw was andy
pointing a camera at you
it was just it's real
i'm glad i'm on the mend anyway then
i've walked around the ward
i just feel i probably went over
few weeks ago what's the first thing you
do when you get out of here
i would like to eat some chicken a nice
cool ginger here
step by step nikolai's progress is slow
but for his family even this was
unimaginable
just a few weeks ago he was really
really really
bad the doctor said was if he's doing a
heart attack for a
heart sailor or something we cannot
notify you so we were crying
and my sister she said we should get
used
without him to live our life and i said
no
we never give hope
[Music]
just as miraculous is the transformation
of michael
the next time we see him he's out of
intensive care
and a different person from the man
whose family
celebrated at the mere movement of his
eyes
three weeks ago i'm naming me
it's all the frontline staff
and then since i don't know for me late
at night
i wish i could mention all the names as
long as i can't even recognize yeah but
they kept you alive
and kept me alive yeah
[Laughter]
finally dima gets to leave intensive
care
but for nurse michelle the good news of
a patient making it off the ward
is tempered by another intake of the
critically ill
i've had three admissions in two days so
you have to kind of stabilize them and
then they go for cts and then they have
lots of interventions so
it's busy yeah it's very very busy when
they're new and then they get settled
yeah and once they're really settled
they go off for the ward
it starts again
[Music]
so with some patients on the road to
recovery what about the hospital itself
sustained by restricting staff holidays
military support hundreds of
redeployments and postponed operations
behind this crisis lies another one
very little kidney failure this time i
know very different different diseases
i'm just early february
and the virus has sapped hospital
resources did you do this one already
shall we do that
perfect and staff energy
[Music]
but there are subtle signs of change one
of them
the arrival of alison neagle at the
hospital
dropped off by husband tony how are you
feeling terry
uh apprehensive and nervous yeah don't
get any more nervous than this
been 18 months so let's hope
this is the one with covid admissions
continuing to fall
a limited number of desperately needed
operations can be resumed
i've got a rare genetic disorder called
polycystic liver disease
and it's got to the point now where
transplant is the only
option to sort of cuming in 12 months
the number of people in england waiting
more than a year for hospital treatment
has risen from 1600 to more than 300
000 at the royal free the liver
department shut down
entirely during the second covet wave
they rang me from the royal free and
said that unfortunately
people on the variant list were
being suspended
i thought i was very kind of strong
mental health-wise
but it turns out that actually you can
only take so much
[Music]
well it's very frustrating it's also you
know devastating for the patients you
know these are patients with end-stage
liver disease who
have a very short life expectancy
uh on the on the liver transplant
waiting list and we know that patients
die on the waiting list basically my
liver is about three or four times the
size it should be
plus it's covered in cysts and they're
full of fluid so it weighs a couple of
stone
where it should only weigh a few pounds
allison's transplant depends on several
factors on the donor liver being a match
on the hospital's ability to muster a
surgical team
and crucially finding space in intensive
care
for her recovery so at the moment we're
taking six coal
um covered beds out i think we also got
to be aware that if our numbers were to
increase again we'd have to
we'd flip it back we'd have to flip it
back to a cohorted coved area again
hello it's my experience
well yes great timing i'm just saying
just going through the
through the bed state team we still have
a lot
of covered patients we're still way over
200 of our normal
icu capacity and as you've seen this
morning we're
we're having to accept patients in from
around london to
relieve stresses on other other
departments
a substantial amount of hospital
activity has had to stop for covid
and so across the country the waiting
list for treatment is growing fast
people still have heart attacks kidney
failure tumors
the royal free and barnet conducted
nearly 500 emergency operations in the
month we were filming
but covid complicates everything
we want to protect those patients who
don't have covered we had a patient who
required itu the other day
and in fact it would have been easier if
he'd had covet because there were beds
for
for him on the covered ward but they
then had to try and create a bed on the
on the
non-covered itu um so that that's a real
challenge
it's why the makeshift covid ward we
visited three weeks earlier
is now being cleaned
to make space for the massive backlog in
treatments and operations
for those without the virus
for allison there is a space the liver
is a match
her transplant can go ahead take some
nice
deep breaths most of the people in this
room are among 500 staff at the hospital
who've adapted their roles
and worked extra hours on covert wards
it's late at night
but this is what they're trained for
have you ever known a time like this
no i think this is as bad as as sharp as
civilian medicine would ever get
from an itu perspective there's there's
almost no end in sight
we have a large group of chrome advised
patients who need
care and support which will be a long
process um sadly we have more
coronavirus patients
to come we have to work our way through
the operations that have not been done
uh that needed to be done
and then after that of course there's
the very real impact of as the scans
start
and the conditions that haven't been
detected really over the past 12 months
they will come to need management as
well that's going to keep the royal free
intensive care units running at well
above
where they were before probably
indefinitely
about an hour into the operation the
liver arrives
packed in ice a gift from someone who's
just died
inside a cool box the chance for alison
to have
a normal life and just a day after
she's well enough to reflect on what's
happened
hello how are you doing okay
how do you feel having someone else's
liver in inside you that's just amazing
it's such a privilege
um you know someone's
family member has had to you know
be such a difficult time for them
um such a privilege
[Music]
just corridors away many are still
fighting the virus kept alive by
machines
and round-the-clock care
and thousands like alison still wait for
these beds
and the attention of these diverted
medics
[Music]
so while life slowly starts to get back
to normal
outside of these walls it may never
in here if i could magically stop
coronavirus now
you know you say right no more
coronavirus patients how long would it
take you to get back to normal
i don't think we'll ever get back to to
normal i can't see how we're going to
return to
the royal free itu as it was at the end
of 2019
i think that's just that's now history
the medics nearly broken themselves have
to pick up the pieces
behind the mask how are they feeling i
think it's been
just such a phenomenally high pressure
environment
and we've all been witness to some
really
unbelievably horrible things with
critically ill patients and just so many
of them
that it's going to take a long time to
process
and a long time to get over you say you
need to break it is that
even possible at the moment no
[Music]
a lot of us don't go home feeling like
we've done a good job and i think
that's one of the hardest things to take
away from
from coronavirus for me especially just
that feeling that
you couldn't do enough for people it's
it's really difficult
[Music]
it felt like the care part went like
and i feel ashamed to say it was like
we're managing bodies
we're trying to keep bodies alive
so i've been in nursing for 20 years
this is like another level
like flashbacks through the night or a
sound will trigger something
yeah i'm not very good at the moment
at least you've got something to look at
i saw a red bus today in my first red
bus which is just down there with that
motorbike
dima is getting ready to go home i did
have a
down date on tuesday it just sort of hit
me that how ill i was
and i just felt a little down but i was
i was okay
after that thinking i'm just lucky that
i'm alive
i just kept saying to myself please i
need to get strong i don't belong here i
don't belong here you know
just to try and get myself you know
motivated
because i just wanted to get myself a
lot better
when she does recover dima will return
to her job
as an nhs caterer for patients on wards
i mean i think we've learned a
phenomenal amount from from the covid
pandemic
i think you know we've managed to
upscale our intensive care
facilities and provision beyond our
wildest dreams i think a year and a bit
ago
if you told me we were gonna have 95
patients on intensive care
at the royal free i would have said it
was totally impossible
i'm more concerned about what's going to
happen after i think
trouble comes when things start settling
down
and we'll see how deep is the
scar that is going to be in the in the
nursing team and the medical team
is that the thing that you find the
hardest to
grapple with that you feel like you
haven't been able to provide the care
that you would have liked to
be yeah to the point
[Music]
to the point that i actually don't know
if i could do another season of it
i'm sure when i've got time to process
it all i will speak to somebody
it's not something you can just pass
[Music]
walk away from after it's all over
you're going to carry that with you oh
definitely carry with me forever
i think everybody will
[Music]
you